The top k algorithm that we have so far.
We talked about using sorting, which runs in time and log n because you sort the whole list
and then you can get any top k that you want for any k so it doesn't depend on k.
The selection and insertion approach is both run in Θ(nk)
essentially because we're repeating for each of the elements that we want to get it out
or repeating something like n work.
But now, we have a fourth approach, which uses this partitioning idea recursively
to get an expected running time Θ(n), which is better and the worst case than sorting
and better than selection/insertion for any k other than a constant n
for constant they come up the same.
This is actually pretty remarkable algorithm.
I actually haven't found much useful in practice. I guess it's sort of nice to know that it's there.
The algorithm that I have found very useful in practice is to use the selection/insertion approach
but to use a different data structure than just a list to do the insertions into and that's a heap.
And what the heap is going to give us is a running time that is (n log k),
which is going to be better than sorting except when it ties it if k is or n,
and it's definitely going to beat the selection/insertion approach.
It doesn't do as well a partition at this particular problem of finding the top k,
but it actually is pretty useful for bunch of other things as well
so let's dive into the whole universe of heaps now.